for those of you who don't know what I'm
talking about there was an experiment
done where they had um I'm going to
butcher it but they had a they put dogs
in a cage and the floor was delivered
electric
shocks and in short order if there was
no way for the dogs to get out the dogs
just sat there and took it even when
they provided a way for the dogs to get
out and move to another part of that
cage where um there was no electric
shock the dogs just sat in it they just
sat in it they they just got shocked and
shocked and shocked the other part of
the experiment was when they would turn
it on and they would have other they it
would be intermittent the dogs learned
all right I can get out of this I can
get out of this I'm GNA keep fighting I
can keep
moving and you just learned to sit there
and take electric shocks brother